we all make fun of Divine Right
monarchies this sort of absurd idea and
it's we view Divine Right monarchs as
being absolute tyrants wielding but that
isn't true the idea of Divine Right
monarchy is actually that there is a
limit on the power of the Monarch
because the Monarch is answerable to God
who is a lot more important and powerful
than a politician who's answerable only
to the people or answerable only to a
small group say in an oligarchy this is
the meaning of John Adams's famous
statement the Constitution is built for
a moral and religious people that's the
constraint when you take that constraint
away in the name of the separation of
church and state or the enlightened
views of secularism and when you take
that away you're going to lose the grace
you're going to lose the restraints
you're going to lose the kiss it up for
vengeance as the Lords and you're going
to get a lot of Wrath
and gluttony and pride and lust and all
the rest of it you're going to get a
country burning to the ground as we have
seen in recent years